so what's on the agenda for today i
first want to talk a little bit about
the example that i'm going to talk about
uh when we watch it when we watch the
code samples later
um and then i would get want to get
everybody on the same page about what
design ideas i wanted to incorporate
and then i'm going to explain to you why
i chose academic as an implementation to
solve this problem and then we'll dive
into some code and i'm gonna show you
some things that you can do to
make this work
and hopefully in less than an hour i'll
be able to wrap it up and
send you off on your next journey
so
what have we been building we are
building beer sender.net why are we
building beer center.net
it was
january this year uh everything was on
lockdown we were all sitting inside
again we had a nice stint of like three
conferences in november december and
then the world
went on lockdown because of a micron
again i was really bummed out i mean i
really like doing this being on stage
getting lots of attention i really hate
doing it at home
behind the webcam so it was bummed out i
figured i'm gonna
spread some cheer
so
my idea came
i live in belgium
and what do we do in belgium better than
any other country in the world is making
beers right
so i figured if i take some of those
beers and i put them in a box
and i send them
to my friends everybody will be happy
right that was my plan
it's a great plan isn't it
so what i did is i went shopping for
beer and i bought uh eight cases of beer
and spread them over eight boxes they
all had 24 different beers in them
so i had a very nice selection of mostly
local beers
um so i picked them up in these nice
boxes that a friend of mine who runs a
micro brewery provided me
and i put shipping labels on them and i
send them on their way
so my expectation was that i would
contact ups
and i would pay them like a handsome
amount of money because these were heavy
boxes
and a handsome amount of money
to deliver these boxes where they needed
to be
so what i expected to happen is i
dropped them off at the ups shipping
point and this would happen right
all my friends happy
but that was not reality
reality was like tracking pages that
look like this and if we zoom in
some of them got returned to me
because as it turns out i do not have a
license to
ship beer outside of the uau
that was something i did not encounter
so some of these boxes were going to
norway and switzerland and the uk so
yeah
um
so what actually happened
was that i was tracking all these
shipments and keeping track of which
ones actually
got stuck in customs i needed to provide
extra content extra info about what was
in the boxes like lots of emails going
back and forth
and then without informing me of
anything that boxes showed up back at my
help desk so i'm trying to call ups help
desk which is like a different layer of
hell all together
to figure out what had gone wrong
um but the packages like half of the
packages returned to me so i had to like
get the shipping costs reimbursed and
send them again then some of them were
shipped correctly now
but there wasn't even a delivery attempt
made it's like hey kevlin did you get
that box it's like no i was i was here
all day i didn't even get a notice in my
mailbox yeah okay but they're returning
the box to me again so i had to
re-recuperate shipping costs and then
send them again and
one of the boxes still hasn't arrived
yet
so
sending beer is tricky i mean making and
filling boxes is a really really fun
activity if you want to to spread cheer
but shipping and keeping track of
everything was really hard
so
to do all that follow-up we need
beercenter.net so i figured i'm going to
build something for them and why do we
call it beers sender.net it was not
built in vb6 so i append net to the name
as we have been doing for
18 years
why do we still do that like
net
right um
but all the fun aside um what we're here
to talk about is the design ideas that i
would use if i were to build such an
application
so if we summarize ddd and for me coming
in contact with ddd was reading this
book by eric evans it's definitely one
of the harder books that i've ever read
it was one of the only books that i
wasn't able to finish in one go and i've
met a lot of people who weren't able to
finish this in one go so i don't feel
inadequate it's just a very
dense book
um but if we summarize it for those of
you who do not have as much experience
in ddds
the general idea is that we're gonna try
and align
the business side of things and the code
side of things
we want to use one language a ubiquitous
language to describe business context
and if possible we would like to convey
that into our code and use the same
context when we're writing that code and
in a high level
if you look at a high level system
you're going to have bounded context a
bounded context is like a certain domain
where you can decide
where that language is applicable
because a person might mean something
completely different when you're
shipping boxes
versus when you're filling them right
when you're filling a box you want to
write a personal note to that person
because here's your friend when you're
shipping boxes you care where they live
and what customs rules will apply if i
try to get that box to them
so that bounded context is important
on a low level we're gonna try to make
our code as expressive as possible we're
gonna get try to get as close to the
business contexts as we can
and for that we need to be able to
separate certain blocks where we reason
about certain things and where all the
all the events and all the commands and
all the code come together and that's
what we call a root aggregate
um it's the root for reasoning about
certain things
now the book itself
is written from a more object-oriented
way of doing things
but if you start
applying dddd especially now today
we are
more often driven towards architectures
like cqrs concepts like event sourcing
and you using commands and events
because they make reasoning about
business context a lot easier you can
apply techniques such as event storming
where you try to describe the flow of
things happening in your organization
so commands and events is an interesting
one um
a command is something you can send into
the system in imperative form it is a
request to perform a certain operation
we're going to write it imperative um
for instance send beer
that would be a good command
an event is a is a notification that
something has happened in our system it
has already taken place there's nothing
you can do to change it
um but you can do something with that
information
so those are written in the past tense
um
for instance beer received
if kathleen finally gets his beer
then i will get that event
so cqrs architectures um this has been
around for a while it's not necessarily
linked to ddd but it's a very nice match
uh what we're going to do with
cqrs is we're going to separate
the command side of replication the
right site where the data is changed
from the side where the data is queried
because it allows us to performance tune
both sides
separately and we have a very clear
boundary it's like a query cannot have
side effects right
it's something that in an
object-oriented
context you might sin against
um so this architecture really enforces
that and it's very very nice
now if we think about our
domain driven design is we want to have
a place where we send a command into the
system
and that command is going to get handled
but a command can actually it cannot
fail you cannot throw an exception and
say like okay this command just didn't
go true what you can do is you can raise
events to communicate to failure or to
communicate the success
but the command itself cannot fail
the command is sent into the system and
you as soon as it is accepted it's going
to be processed with certain results
and those command handlers they will
talk to your
true database where you are
able to
see what the truth of the data at that
moment is
and depending on the success failure
whatever might happen you're going to
raise a bunch of events to communicate
what has happened after you triggered
that command
and those events they will go on an
event bus
and on the
read side of things you can subscribe to
those events and use that to project
your data to prepare it for read storage
and then you can
you can use your queries to just hit
read
the read database
just in performance terms what is really
powerful about this is that if for every
query you're going to define in your
system you could make sure that it hits
a table
on an index and it's going to be a
single table select
performance will always be snap fast if
you can achieve that and this
architecture allows you to do that
really quickly
and then there's the last thing
event sourcing is a concept that
also can be applied in different
contexts than ddd
but it maps really well again if you
think about event sourcing you can think
about stair um
storing the state that your replica that
your data is
in at a certain moment
but you lose
the history of what happened to it
what caused this data to be in the shape
that it is in today
for instance a shopping cart is an
example that is often used with this um
if you put product a into your shopping
cart and then you see in the suggestions
like you see product b and you think oh
that might be better i'm going to put
that in and throw a out again those are
all events you put a in
put b in take a out and there's a lot of
valuable
information in that especially if you're
building a recommendation engine for
your shopping carts
um so the concept of event sourcing is
instead of
storing the state we're just going to
store all the events that led to the
state because if we replay the events we
can reconstruct the state
but we don't lose everything that led up
to where we wanted to be at that moment
so if we try and batch all these
concepts together because i like all of
them
that is what i wanted to do with my beer
sender so i wanted to do some kind of
cqrs system where i have a separate
query site and a separate
command site i wanted to build my
aggregates
in a very clean way i want to make them
if possible completely framework
agnostic so that
if ever i can plug them into something
else
that's what we developers do right we
over optimize everything they shouldn't
do that but
but what i really want to get at is i
want to have very nicely written tests
tests that even if i show them in code
to my product owner
they can reason with me about those
tests that is one of the most important
things that we're trying to achieve
so when i talk about all these things
saying like hey honest why didn't you
use a cqrs framework why are you
choosing an actor model well
there's a bunch of things that help us
inside an actor model
so for those who don't know where net
comes from it is a straight up port from
jvm aka um
which was written a couple of years
before aka.net started
um so since 2015 this is the official
port it was two projects that were
combined
um roger johansson who is now working on
proto actor and aaron stannard who is
running petabridge who support aka.net
they were independently porting account
to the net ecosystem
and they learned about each other's
efforts they joined forces um and
academic came out and they even got
permission from leidbent the company
that was behind
jvm aka
to call it akubonet and that's where we
are
now the ideas of doing actor models they
are not new they are there since the
1970s
and they have been refined um
i don't know why most of the things that
we're using today are around for such a
long time but they are
um probably because they got less
distracted by their smartphone and
social media in those times
um but their idea is we're gonna model
our code after the way the world works
we are all objects like these chairs and
rooms or objects and
things interact with each other so can
we not model our software
in that way that was their whole idea
and they they used reactive patterns to
do that to build something that was
highly concurrent
now multiprocessor pcs were not a thing
at that time
um multiple
systems tied together in a network were
the first time they brought this into
practice
was when erickson built the
axd 301 telco system in the 1980s they
invented a whole new programming
language for that which was erlang and
they managed to use the actor model to
get an uptime on those telco systems in
clusters of nine nines
so 99.979
percent uptime that's about 30 31
milliseconds a year of downtime
who gets that kind of uptime
i'd love to talk to you after this talk
um
but yeah i mean very impressive and that
was the first application but then we
had
like a couple of decades
where nothing really happened with these
actors
but then we had the explosion of the
internet we had iot we had
app stores where certainly you could
have an application that was featured
and you would go from 200 to 2 million
users over the course of a day
and so we need something that scales
really well and that's why in 2015 we
got a lot of different actor models on
the net ecosystem we got
service fabric reliable actors project
orleans was released which microsoft
used to build the backend for halo
and we got this
so that explosion caused all of this to
be readapted and becoming more popular
now than it was a decade ago
so to do actors um the basic building
block is of course the actor and
the way you reason about this in.net
code it is a simple object that holds
its own state
right because when you're writing
when you're writing concurrent code
what is always going to hold you back is
the fact that you're going to have at
some point state that needs to be
accessed from multiple threads
and that is always going to cause issues
you're going to implement locking and
locking is not nice it might cause
deadlocks and so on
so to avoid all of that
what we do with actors is we only have a
single threat running on an actor at any
given time
and this is extremely powerful because
as an actor you know that the fields
that are
internal to you
your own state that you're going to be
the only threat accessing that data when
you're processing a message
and that is very very powerful there's
no need for locking there is no
deadlocks occurring there's also no
waiting for any other threats to finish
once you get a message dispatched to
your internal behavior the code that
executes against that internal state you
can just run through it in a couple of
milliseconds and be done with it
so those actors are the building blocks
of our actor system and that single
threadedness as i said is really
important now what does that look like
we can inherit from the simplest actor
class in the echo.net framework being
untyped actor
and all we need to do is implement the
on receive methods that is what our
messages will get dispatched into if we
want we can check what type of message
we have and we're good to go
now those messages um
they're even simpler we don't need to
implement anything not even an interface
you can just have any dotnet object as a
message
only thing is it needs to you need to be
able to serialize it so all the public
fields need to be accessible
you can perfectly like
net record types are perfect for
messages i mean you're immutable by
default
um
but it's best to design or at least
treat your messages as immutable
akka.net doesn't enforce
the immutability on messages so you
might change the content of a message
while an actor is processing it
and if your message didn't cross a
machine library that a machine boundary
that would be possible
but
um
just don't do that you're going to have
a bad time
the throughput that the light band
people claim on akka.net is about 50
million messages per second on the
server
um after the latest update of both.net
and academic i get 4 million on my
laptop and that's a 5 year old laptop so
i have no reason to doubt those numbers
on a beefy server that is definitely
going to be possible
but to do all the orchestration like the
hard part right we have those inboxes
that need to be managed and managed we
need a threat pool
that those messages get dispatched to
certain actor in
instances on
we want to manage our memory because
every actor is going to take up some
memory so the actor system is actually
going to instantiate actors for us and
spin them down again and maybe
re-instantiate them if we need them all
stuff like that is managed by the big
puppet master which is the actor system
coincidentally this is the first
metallica cd i bought when i was young
so that should date me somewhere right
um
but the actor system does all that heavy
lifting for us and luckily we don't need
to do a lot of work so
making an actor system is as simple as
instantiating it with the factory method
and giving it a name
now as i said the actor system is
responsible for creating our actor
instances
we never have a reference to that actor
in hand
we're only going to get
a reference to our actor
and what we need to do that to tell the
actor system to create our actor in the
correct way
is we have something called props
and props um can be adequately described
as being a constructor pointer you're
going to point at the constructor of
your actor class and you're going to
tell it which parameters
to use
in this case i'm using the default
constructor i didn't pass any
parameters but this just takes a params
array and you can pass whatever needs to
go into your constructor in this props
method
and that tells the actor system how to
create your actor
if you want to create a root actor
what you do is you do system.actoroff
you give your actor a name
you pass in the props and then your
actor system knows what to do and what
you get back is an i actor ref
the ix2rf is a very very powerful thing
it is a small object that allows you to
talk to that actor instance
now if for some reason the actor system
has
spinned your actor down and needs to
recreate it you can still use that actor
f and if you talk to it the message goes
into the inbox the actor system will
spin your actor back up again and the
message will go true so this is a
decoupling between stalking to an actor
and the actual implementations and the
actual objects in memory
and if you want to send a message to an
actor you can simply use the message
tell you pass in your message and you're
good to go
simple right
now as i said we create what we did now
is we created a top level actor
but actors live in a hierarchy
you have the three blue ones at the top
they're always there the root actor the
user and the system actor and underneath
the system actor we have a whole bunch
of actors that do things like the event
bus
the inbox management address scheduling
all that sort of stuff you usually don't
touch that
under the user actor is where you create
yours so if you do system.actor off
you're creating a top level actor
probably the a1 or the a2 and destroy
and your address is defined by your
position in that hierarchy so the one at
the bottom right is called slash user
slash a2 b3
now this is important because this has
two implications
one
if you are the child of a certain actor
your name needs to be unique you cannot
have three b3s under a2 you can have a
b3 under a1 but you cannot have three
b3s under a2 so
at some point you're going to be putting
id ids in actor names
um
another thing is that this hierarchy
becomes important where we're going
towards that
error handling that i'm going to talk to
about in the next slide
now how do you create children
instead of doing system.actoroff we have
um oh i'm going to go back and describe
that in a second instead of
[Music]
system.extraf you do context.actroff
so when you're processing a message on
an actor
um you have something that is the
context is the execution context it will
tell you stuff about where is this
message message coming from where is it
going um which actor am i stuff like
that and if you do context dot actor off
what you're doing is you're creating a
child
right
now what you see here is we don't have
an untyped actor i have a receive actor
and for you who are working as net
developer this will feel
so much more familiar
compared to the untyped actor this is
the typed version and instead of having
this generic on receive that takes in an
object
you get to register your
your message handlers
so you can just
do a receive for every type of message
that this actor is expecting and you can
register which method is going to handle
it when it comes in this feels a lot
more familiar for the net developers
right
so use these they're better
um
but what i said like error handling um
any of you have children
i do i have three
um
yeah
you can feel pity for me um
if you take your kids into a supermarket
who is responsible is it your kids
yes
oh that's hopeful i'd like to talk to
you about parenting later
um
so are your kids responsible when they
knock something over when they run their
shopping cart into
an old lady's angles whatever no you're
going to be the one apologizing
apologizing you're going to be the one
fixing their mistakes and it is no
different in an actor system if a child
actor throws
an unhandled exception
that exception is escalated to the
parent and the parent can decide how to
handle this
um
some actions aren't some exceptions
aren't that bad
so you can tell the actor to resume it's
like okay this wasn't that bad just pick
up the next message from your inbox and
you can continue
sometimes it's really bad when you see a
kid like painting its bedroom wall
you're gonna shout stop it's like stop
whatever you're doing right
um that terminates the actor don't do
that to your kids okay don't terminate
your kids um
but you're gonna tell the actor to stop
you're gonna delete the instance they're
gonna delete the inbox like you're done
um
restart is a little bit more friendly it
is like okay go ahead try again you
failed this time but it might be
that you succeed next time and the cool
thing about restart is it actually
deletes your actor instance
recreates it with the same props that it
was originally created with
and then it dispatches the same message
again and the end the inbox is preserved
so if you have some kind of transient
exception that you might recover from
restart is a very nice thing that you
could try
or if you don't know what to do anymore
it's like when your kids are really
misbehaving it's like i'm gonna ask my
dad how he dealt with me when i was that
age so you can escalate the um
you can escalate the exception to the
grandparent as well right
and you can do this for one failing
actor or for all your children um
this makes sense in a context this is a
pattern that you see a lot when you're
dealing with actors is if you have a
huge workload what you can do is you can
cut it up into small pieces and then
dispatch all those pieces to different
child actors so that they can all
execute in parallel
but if one exception would invalidate
the entire workload you don't want all
the other child actors to continue
processing so you're gonna want to stop
them all so you want your supervision
strategy to apply to all the child
actors
now this is a bit abstract how you do
that in code is you implement the you
overwrite the supervisor strategy method
and you're going to return something um
one for one means i'm going to apply
this only to the failing child
and depending on what exception you get
in you can
you have this
selector method that you can use
to figure out what directive you want to
give back
um so if you have something fatal you're
going to want to maybe stop that child
if it's transient you could restart and
if you don't know what to do anymore you
can escalate right so this is how that
works you just implement that one method
and you you pass it back
in the supervisor strategy methods and
that will apply to any failing child
exceptions
now this is this is the the this is what
made it possible for them to get down to
those milliseconds per year down times
right everything that fails needs to be
caught somewhere and handled
appropriately
and then there is a last thing i've been
talking about objects that hold their
own internal state
um
and how those objects get recreated by
the actor system and as you might guess
correctly that would mean that allstate
is lost
right at some point there's some actors
where you're actually going to care
about the state that's in them
you're going to want to persist that
somewhere in a database so that when the
actor is recreated you can actually
recover
um
to do that we can use the akka
persistence library and the echo
persistence library is very very
powerful you need to
give your actor a unique persistence id
that is what it's going to use to
store everything into the data store
that you choose
and it supports like a whole bunch of
things you can put it in azure table
storage or in a sql database or in
mongodb whatever
um you're going to have to give it a
persistence id and now you have
different methods you don't no longer
have a receive method but you're going
to have recover and commands
instead
now how this works is inside your actor
you can snapshot your own state
and save that to a database if you want
and when the actor is recreated what it
will do is it will get that snapshot
from the the snapshot storage and then
it will get all the events that have
happened since that snapshot and replay
those and then it will start accepting
messages from the inbox
and if you have paid attention to my
introduction this maps pretty closely to
what event sourcing is right so this is
built in event sourcing
now this is this is a pretty long actor
i think it's spread across three slides
um so what we're looking at we're now
using persistent actors you only get
those when you install the persistence
package
um
so you need to give it that persistence
id which is
which is just a string
and what i usually do is i group all of
my state into a single state object and
makes reasoning about it a lot easier
right when you're snapshotting and
recovering snapshots that becomes a lot
easier to handle but you don't have to
do that it's just me who does that
um and as i said you no longer have a
receive meta you now have a command and
a recovery and what's the difference
between those command comes from the
inbox
and recover comes from your event store
and why would you want to treat those
two differently you want to treat them
differently because an incoming command
might actually want to save that to the
event store but when you're recovering
you don't want to re-save that again
right
and so that's why they come in in a
different way and then we can do a whole
bunch of things with snapshots
and
the reason that there are so many
snapshots methods is because
saving a snapshot is something that
happens out of thread
so when you're cue when you're
calling these save snapshots inside a
persistent actor
it spawns a different thread that will
save that to disk for you it's not going
to happen in sync
so that's why you can subscribe to
certain events that come back to see if
that saving was successful or was a
failure
um
now how do we persist messages um
there is a persist method that takes the
message that you want to write
inside um that you want to write to your
event store
and then you call a certain method that
will mutate your state
and then
knows what to do because all of these go
up to a stack and they are all processed
when the
the thread is done
so
this persist method is important and
that is how you make sure that it gets
persistent
um
and
we just add that in our state that
internal that handle message internal is
the one that we are going to call on a
recovery it's also the one that will
actually do all the view dating for us
and so it makes sense to for instance
keep track of um how many messages were
since your last snapshot you might want
to do that in the internal one that that
way your calendar is recreated even on a
recovery
snapshot against in your own hands you
can just call safe snapshot whenever you
want you don't have to
so if you figure that we are building
actors that will never get more than 100
messages in their lifetime why would you
want to save snapshots just save all the
events replay them it'll be faster
and when you get a snapshot back when
you're recovering when the actor
restarts it looks like that
you get a snapshot offer message and
inside the offer is an object that is
your state if you group everything in a
state object like me this is all the
code you need so this is why this is
handy otherwise you're
recreating a whole bunch of different
fields and you can subscribe to those
two messages if you want didn't do
anything with it here
but sometimes it might be important to
know if a certain snapshots
succeed succeeded or failed
so as you could have guessed from this
description
um
both
ddd
and actors have a philosophy that
they're modeling the code after real
world
in ddd we're trying to bring the
business and the code together in actors
we are bringing like the objects as
close to the way objects work in the
real world
boats
map very well with message driven
approaches the event source persistence
is built in
we even have an event bus and as a
benefit it's very high throughput there
is cluster support and so on so it felt
like a good match
so how do we bring all of these into
practice
for our beer sender
now as a disclaimer none of this is
production ready code i oversimplified
some things what i want to show you is
which features of academ might come in
handy when you're building something
like this um
it's all about what's possible and what
you can do
so when we're talking about aggregates
um
i said that i wanted to build my
aggregates if at all possible
in a framework agnostic way
and so that
they don't know anything about the
storage and then i can write really nice
and clean tests for them
so you don't have to define an interface
i just did to make it clear in the stock
what i want to do is i want to have
two methods on my aggregate
the first is like i want to check what
would happen if i would
execute a certain command
and that will give me a bunch of events
back
right
i could have chosen to make this already
mutate the internal state of the
aggregate for reasons that we will see
later i did not so this just checks like
if you would execute this command right
now
what which events would i get and then i
have the apply event method which is
actually the thing that will apply that
event to a certain state
it's all a recovery thing it all pieces
together in a second
so my root aggregate is a single
shipment of beer i'm gonna send the box
to rene over there right
which i did
and so i'm gonna send a single box of
beer
so some of the fields that i care about
are my shipment id i want to see if
there's already beers in it um all the
states are just
fields nothing more nothing less
and because we we will serialize this
entire aggregate as a snapshot we are
already done for persistence
with this part
now my check command is actually going
to do something
do i have highlights in the slides no i
don't
um the check command method is going to
take certain commands in and see what
would happen
and then you'll get
methods like the one in the bottom if i
get the send beers command i want to
check if there's already beers in the
box
and that i attach the shipping label to
it because otherwise nothing is going to
get sent
and
there's nothing else to do for those
handle command
methods to raise a certain number of
events beer send or the beer send fails
um
if we're thinking about applying events
we're gonna get certain events in and we
are going to apply them into the
internal state of our aggregate
and usually that doesn't mean anything
else like a method at the bottom
if a shipment is created if that event
is applied to this aggregate and because
it is applied to this aggregate we know
that it was already checked right
because that happened in the check
command method so we don't have to worry
about all the conditions we can just
apply the event to our state the
conditions are checked in the check
command
if we want to write very expressive
tests around that i made in a base
aggregate test class
and that takes in our aggregate and i
implemented things for a given when and
then which is a very um
a very
commonly used pattern of writing tests
um the given is just a bunch of events
the given is these events have already
taken place
and then i'm gonna try and raise a
command so my when is going to take a
command and it's going to dispatch that
command to my
aggregate and then on the expect
from that command i'm expecting to get a
bunch of events back
right and this message this method is
just gonna match that against the list
that my
aggregate actually raised after that
command
so what we would get
is a test
that my product owner would probably
understand
if i create a new shipment with a
certain shipment id
and i add a gaud and carroll's quadruple
whiskey infused to it which means that
my box now has beer in it and i add a
shipping label with trackmay123
if i would try to send that box i expect
that the beers are sent
if you can have this type of tests
about your pretty low level code
you're gonna bridge the gap with those
people
and you can even write those tests
together with product owners and i think
that's a very very powerful thing and i
think that's a lot of what ddd is about
it's like bridging that gap
but now we have an aggregate that is
agnostic it has nothing to do with
actors yet right
so we're gonna need to wrap that
aggregate inside beside an actor
and i chose to do it with a generic
implementation that would apply to all
actors that implement that interface
and i chose for that actor to also
handle the persistence um which is
quite powerful
so we did the receive persistent actor
and i
chose as a persistent id the type of
actor and the id of the actor that is an
easy thing to do and i'm just gonna
subscribe to events
there's also subscribing to comments
just below it
um but there is a difference between the
apply event that comes from recovery and
the one that comes from
my inbox
and that is the difference is that we're
gonna need to persist it if it comes
from the inbox
now
in the snapshot we just replace our
aggregate because we saved that with
with all of its fields into the database
and
if we get new events and this is that
apply event persistence has already
happened if it needed to happen all
we're going to do is dispatch that event
to our aggregate
we don't need to do anything else
and then underneath you can see oh you
can see that we implemented that same
100 messages i'm gonna snapshot but you
can do whatever
if you want actors to save a snapshot
every one hour
there are mechanisms that allow you to
schedule messages to your own actor
all of that is possible
and then the last thing is like when a
new command comes in i'm going to check
it against the aggregate
and all of the events that are coming
that are going to come out i'm going to
persist those
and this is why i wrote that interface
the way that i wrote it is
because we are applying the state now in
the persist methods
together with the event that has
happened
i now have a nice and clean event stream
for my actor when it comes back from
persistence
one more thing that we do here um so
we're doing the check command and we're
sit we're persisting them all one thing
one line you see here is the event
stream i'm gonna come back to that in a
couple of slides
so when we make new
aggregate actors all we need to do is
implement it with the right
aggregate type and you're already done
now let's talk about how we're going to
build an entire actor system around
these aggregate actors because we can
now spawn a bunch of these
but there's a little bit more to do
so the way that i think this should look
is
we have a command router on the left
which is an actor that is going to be
responsible for all the commands that
come in on that command side of our cqrs
system
that actor is going to talk to
the aggregate manager which is right
next to it and that actor has only one
responsibility it's like if an actor
doesn't exist yet it's going to create
it as a child and it's going to pass the
iactor rev back to the command router so
that command router can send its command
to that specific aggregate
now
for reasons we're going to also want to
have our
read storage
separate from that so we're going to
have a bunch of actors that are
projecting the event stream into our
read storage right
so for every type of event that we want
to deal with in our read storage we're
going to make a projector i'll come back
to those in a minute as well
and then you might want to fold certain
events back into your aggregates
so some aggregates might respond to
respond to events that were not created
by themselves
and for that you can also subscribe to
the event stream it's a very similar
mechanism and you can use fold actors
for that
so that was all that
so
the aggregate manager it
takes a connect request and there's a
couple of things that are very handy
inside icon.net you have for instance
a sender that is being
set
when um
when you're dis when you're processing a
message from your inbox it's a property
that is being set on your actor you can
assume that that was the actor that
actually sent you the message that
you're dealing with at the moment
so when you do sender.tell what you're
doing is basically replying to the actor
that sent you that message
so if you have that
aggregate manager what it could do is
like okay if i don't have this child yet
i'm going to create it and send the iac
tariff back and it will create one
aggregate per
um instance
now the command router is something
different um it will just cache all the
actor refs that it has from all the
aggregates if commands come in it will
talk to them
um pretty simple it will just relay
messages
um
the problem with this actor is that it
may become a bottleneck because as as
you might have may have sugges already
assumed
if you have an actor that gets more
messages than a single threat on your
cpu can process
your inbox is going to keep growing
indefinitely and that is going to hurt
you because that actor is going to
become like a point of failure in your
system
inbox overflow is a thing that might
happen
and those projectors we are going to
create at the start of our system
because if we want to subscribe to the
event stream for certain types of events
that happened because they need to
mutate our read storage
um
the actors need to be there otherwise
the messages will not get dispatched so
those are um the projector creator will
actually create all the projectors for
us so that they can subscribe themselves
to the events and things can happen
and the faults is very similar um
i have to watch the time a little bit
and it's very similar they will
subscribe themselves upon system startup
and they will basically relay certain
events to certain aggregates
now the event bus the event bus is
something that is built in um into
akka.net it is even on a cluster level
so if you have multiple actor systems
working together as a cluster the
eventbus is a
cluster
site affair
publishing is really easy you just do
the context is the message processing
context that we talked about earlier you
can do
context.system.eventstream and then
publish whatever message you want to put
on the bus um
you can put you can do this from an
actor you can also do it from outside
the actor system if you have a reference
to the actor system you can access the
event stream as well
if you want to subscribe
an actor to
that event stream we can call that a
subscribe method and when we do the
subscribe we can pass a certain actor
and we can tell it which type of message
we're interested in
and mind you there is no filter so you
cannot say i'm interested in these type
of messages for that aggregate id that's
a possibility that this event bus
doesn't have
so that's why i decided that i needed
one projector for each message type and
that is going to
handle all of the messages that come
into that
now
the pre-start method i didn't talk about
that yet that's a meta that gets called
on the actor before it starts accepting
messages from the inbox
um so when you instantiate a new actor
and it needs to do things before it
actually
starts accepting messages the pre-start
method is what you would want to use
such as subscribing yourself to the
eventbus
now that command router that i talked
about that might be a bottleneck right
um
and cool thing they already solved that
for us
um in box overflow is is a potential
problem
for
an actor
and you can solve that using routers um
in aku.net you can treat a pool or a
group of actors as one and they will get
a single address and you can basically
decide to distribute the inbox messages
across those actors so that you
basically have a multi-threaded
processor for one
inbox and you can use different routing
strategies you can do round robins like
one for each and then start at the
beginning again when you're at the end
you can also look at the inboxes of all
your
actors in your pool and decide to send
it to the one that has the smallest
inbox
or you can do consistent hashing and
that might also be interesting in an
aggregate context consistent hashing is
where you're going to inspect your
message
and decide based on the properties of
that message
which hash that message will get and if
you would use your aggregate id as a
hash that means that all the messages
for that same aggregate id would go to
the same
actor in your routing pool
it might be something you don't want or
it might be something you want but it's
something you can use
and configuring routers is actually not
that hard you do it
when you create your props and you tell
it instead of just creating one i want
you to have a router with a round robin
pool with five instances and what this
will do
is this will create five command routers
for us and just round robin to them we
don't need to do anything else we can
still talk to that one eye actor ref
that we get back
and all those messages will get
distributed so if you have bottleneck
actors there are solutions this is
something you might want to apply to
maybe your projectors or your fold
your folds as well if those are becoming
a problem so this can be solved
we're 10 minutes out
which means that i want to leave a
little bit of room for questions
[Music]
so if we summarize what we saw
today
we're gonna wrap aggregates and actors
we're gonna wrap our protectors
projectors and actors
our commands our messages our events our
messages and the event sourcing is built
in
so our conclusion is that
domain driven design and actors really
match really well there is
not a lot of friction between the two
concepts you can very easily build a
c-qrs system without needing a framework
um
and that in my opinion makes it really
nice to mix those two
now there's a whole bunch of things that
we did not talk about today there's like
a whole bunch of things that you can
expand further upon this for instance
you might want
to expose your event stream or part of
your event stream back to your ui
so maybe you will have an actor that
publishes messages from the event stream
to a signalr hub so that your ui can
subscribe to some of those messages
um if you're configuring actor systems
and that's a whole
a whole different hornet's nest and
you're gonna have to use hulk on
configuration hogan stands for human
optimized configuration object notation
it's something that looks like json but
isn't really json it's like exactly what
we need right another configuration
language
um
it's not really that hard but it's
something that allows you to
bring some of the stuff
that you normally do in code to the
outside for instance
you could configure that pool size for
that router actor you could configure
that in hokon so that you don't need to
rebuild your application if you want to
change the number of um
of router of rooties in that in that
pool clustering is also something we
didn't talk about in depth but know that
you can
have actor systems work together as a
big cluster you can have nodes that have
certain roles
you can have
you can chart your actors across a bunch
of nodes and talk to them without
knowing where they are
um all that sort of stuff is really
powerful and what is cool to know is
that if an eye actor ref passes a
machine boundary or goes outside of your
actor system
it has something called location
transparency and location transparency
means you don't have to care on which
node that actor is if you have the actor
if you can talk to it and that is that's
pretty cool
logging is something that we also didn't
talk about but there are adapters for
pretty much any logging or observability
framework that you would care about
um so
explore the packages uh dive into that
and the last thing is the the only paid
tool that the people from pedobridge
offer
because acco.net is free it's open
source
but there is a production monitoring
system costs about four thousand euros a
year
um what that allows you to do is monitor
how many actor systems uh actor
instances are in memory at the moment
how big the inboxes are uh what your
average time to processing is and so on
you get a whole bunch of metrics for
monitoring a huge actor system in
production if you're serious about this
like look into that it's going to help
you a lot
if you want to learn more there is a
very cool
free boot camp on
on github
it is maintained by the
pedobridge people it will walk you
through all of the basic content
concepts of building actor systems
their blog is amazing every new feature
that they put out they blog about
extensively
um
which means that you can find a lot of
the stuff that you want to know over
there without looking for it they have
paid training as well the training is
really good it is given by the people
who actually build all this
so that is very valuable
my name is hannes i'm the head of
learning and development for a company
called access in belgium that is my
twitter handle and my icq number i'm
trying to make icq great again
and
yeah
i've been doing this for four years
nobody ever messaged me on icq so
let today be the first um
do any of you have questions oh i have
to go back
they do have an app though on ios and
on android so
the trouble for me was reviving that icq
number which meant that i needed to
reactivate my hotmail account so
so any questions
yes
right
good question
um we have a bunch of actor systems
right and they all do their own things
um
better and their own things worse than
the others
for instance
in the beginning orleans was really
built towards that real-time
communication because it was meant to be
the back end for halo
whereas
akka.net was a really nice middle ground
[Music]
and service fabric reliable actors were
very enterprisey but i would argue that
they weren't real actors if you would
just
dispatch a message to a downstream actor
the threat in the main actor was paused
so getting like real performance out of
that wasn't really possible but it made
for very robust processes
and proto-actor works a little bit
different from akka.net whereas like
clustering and where your actors go is
not something you worry about so much in
proto-actor as you would in
archaeolognet
um i'm just most familiar with akka
which is i chose this as an example but
i'm guessing that you can probably do
ddd and cqrs in in any of them um
so yeah for this case no real reason
um for me it felt like the when i got
into actors it was the best middle
ground that i
found for the cases that we were working
with at that time which was an iot
solution
was that too honest
any other questions
oh the message queuing system it's it's
actually has its own
built-in
message queuing system so if you want to
connect it to an outside message queue
that would completely be possible um
maybe publish them to the event stream
or dispatch them to
uh to the messages but like the the
message queuing is built in
me
yes
well it has at most one's delivery it
gets very close to one um when you have
memory pressure what the actor system
will do is it will spin down actors
like try and free up the ram from those
actors because it will remember the um
props
that they were created with and it can
recreate them
but at some point you might run out yes
um and then you're going to lose them
and then you get at most one's delivery
oh yeah if you turn the machine off yes
everything is gone so if you do yeah
that's something i also didn't touch on
on this slide i touch on it on in my iot
slide deck
is if you want to redeploy your system
what you're going to need to do is pause
all the input make sure that all the
actors get done processing and then turn
it off and redeploy
but yes you will lose messages when you
recycle your your actor systems
no not really
it's still very close
and the people at light bend are
building a lot of products on top of
uh their jvm arca
things that we don't have in the
net ecosystem yet
so there's a couple of products that
they're making that we that
net doesn't have answers to but the
original implementation is really close
to
um what jvm archive is
yes
persistence happens on an actor level so
everything that has been persisted that
is not lost what was in the inboxes
that's in memory
no no like the the memory overhead for
an actor in a release build is about 400
bytes
that is if you don't have any state in
it right you just create something that
inherits from an untyped actor 400 bytes
so you can easily have millions of
actors on a single machine
that is not going to be an issue
so a lot is like
hundreds of millions then you might
consider a cluster
um but like a couple million actors it's
not gonna be a big deal
okay
if you want to talk more hit me up in
the hallway i'll be here until friday
for those of you who still are in town
on friday we're going to do pub conf
there are a couple of tickets left it's
going to be really fun
um there'll be funny talks and us
embarrassing ourselves
and the ticket includes food and beer so
feel free to sign up and join us on
friday in the barley mo
have a nice last two talks of your
conference and i hope to see you later
you